back for a second day of protest despite
an earlier crackdown
a meeting with the country's deputy
finance minister and then a march to the
parliament while the demonstrators
demanded the government reverse what
they called punitive economic policies
today the ordinary kenyan
is struggling to afford three square
meals a day not even two square meals a
day
because we are suffering
from 14 ghana cities in 2016
the price of a gallon of diesel and
petrol has galloped to a hopping 61
ghana cities
today the price of a bag of cement
has galloped from 28 gunner cities
to 62 galaxies the rising cost of living
is one reason demonstrators are on the
streets but organizers say they're also
concerned about political corruption
increases in taxes as well as alleged
cases of human rights abuses by security
forces they say all these are combining
to make life difficult for most people
here in ghana
members of parliament say they are aware
of the country's growing economic and
social problems
we will do what is needful the petition
itself will tolerate thoroughly be
debated on the floor of parliament and
positions taken but my first advice
would be for the president to hold
momentarily all petroleum-related taxes
to save
their lives and improve the quality of
living of ghanaians
on tuesday the protests turned ugly as
demonstrators clashed with police who
say at least a dozen officers were hurt
and vehicles damaged
the demonstrator said police fired
rubber-coated steel bullets at them and
arrested dozens
less than two years into his second term
ghana's president nana okofado is coming
under increasing pressure the economy is
faltering unemployment is rising and
inflation has reached its highest level
in decades analysis the government in
parliament must quickly act to calm and
already agitated population ahmadiyya
al jazeera accra ghana